un anuncio para muchos previsibles el
presidente de sergio matare la disuelve
el parlamento con un estado oficialmente
común y como se ha anunciado
oficialmente en firmado el decreto de
disolución de las cámaras para que se
celebren nuevas elecciones en el plazo
de 70 días que exige la constitución
tanta jornet indica toda la constitución
las elecciones anticipadas serían
posiblemente en septiembre por ahora
mario draghi seguirá en el cargo al
frente de un gobierno provisional la
renuncia de draghi como primer ministro
sumió a italia en la incertidumbre
política los periódicos italianos fueron
implacables vergüenza rezaba el titular
de la stampa italia traicionada decía
otro en las calles de roma se vivía la
misma consternación
realmente no es el momento adecuado para
una crisis de gobierno este debería
haber sido el momento de volver a
ponernos en pie
creo que ha sido un movimiento
imprudente por no tener en cuenta todo
lo que está ocurriendo a nivel mundial
con la guerra todo lo que está
sucediendo al liberar la pandemia en
curso
y
los sondeos de opinión sitúan al partido
democrático de centroizquierda cabeza a
cabeza con el partido de extrema derecha
hermanos de italia que se opuso a la
coalición de draghi desde el principio
pero hermanos de italia podría imponerse
formando una coalición con sus aliados
el partido de centroderecha forza italia
y la derechista liga de matteo salvini